this year's short films are innovative
profoundly moving
and worthy of nominations in every
category
set in locations around the world they
show us the best
and worst in ourselves if you love
movies you need to see
these films here are the nominees for
best live action short film
detainment vincent lamb and darren mahen
fov jeremy comte and maria gracia torjon
margarite marianne farley and marie
ellen panisei
mother rodrigo sorigoyan and maria del
puy alvarado
skin guy native and jamie ray newman
and the oscar goes to
skin guy native and jamie ray newman
this is the first oscar nomination for
guy native
and jamie ray newman academy awards for
live
action short films have been presented
for over 80 years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god okay i moved here five years
ago from israel
israel hi and my grandparents are
holocaust survivors and
you know the bigotry that they
experience in the holocaust
we see that everywhere today in america
in europe
and this film is about education it's
about
teaching your kids a better way
uh we we dedicate this to our oh my god
our five-month-old baby who's sitting at
home with my parents
watching this we hope that you grow up
in a world where these things
don't happen because because people
learn to love and accept each other i
want to thank
andrew caulbrook should i roll my moan
tim harms all our team at icm
our maven girls celine trudy oren if
you're out there who's
[ __ ] soul slides you